Speaker 1: Hey, this is this is really, really
interesting because there's the virus.
There's a viral video floating around now
of Senator Brian Schatz just eviscerating
Republican Senator Josh Hawley over his attempts
to delay Joe Biden's Defense Department nominees.
And the video is great because of the substance
and because of the content.
But the video is also great because it's a
reminder of the strategy that Democrats should
be taking should be taking when it comes to
fighting Republicans.
And, you know, remember when Michelle Obama
said, when they go low, we go high.
And I've said many times before we should
not go down to their level of lying and the
just these corrosive attacks on democracy
in order to win.
We shouldn't do that.
But when it comes to rhetoric and style and
tone and strategy, we absolutely need to be
doing some of the things that the right does
because otherwise we're just going to keep
losing.
So let's get to this video clip in this video
clip.
You are going to hear Senator Schatz really
just crush Josh Hawley, who was, by the way,
one of the main pro insurrection senators.
Let's listen, and then we'll discuss.
Speaker 2: He could have brought his floor
charts out here and given a withering speech
about what all of the things that he thought
went wrong.
But he's doing a very specific thing.
He's damaging the Department of Defense.
We have senior DOD leaders, right?
We have the Armed Services Committee coming
to us and saying, I don't know what to tell
him.
I don't know how to satisfy him.
But he is blocking the staffing of the senior
leadership at the Department of Defense, and
this comes from a guy who raised his fist
in solidarity with the insurrectionists.
True.
And this comes from a guy who, before the
Russian invasion, suggested that maybe it
would be wise for Zelensky to make a few concessions
about Ukraine and their willingness to join
NATO.
Oh boy.
This comes from a guy who just about a month
ago voted against Ukraine aid.
He's saying it's going too slow.
He voted no.
He voted no on Ukraine aid.
And now he has the gall to say it's going
to slow.
And this final insult is that until what Secretary
Austin resigns, that's not a serious request.
People used to come to me during the Trump
administration all the time.
Do you think Trump should resign?
Do you think Tillerson should resign?
That's a stupid.
Of course.
I think all the people I disagree with should
quit their jobs and be replaced with people
I love.
Of course, I think they should all resign.
That's not how this world works.
It is not a reasonable request from a United
States senator that until the Secretary of
Defense quit his job, I'm going to block all
of his nominees.
That's preposterous.
And coming from a person who exonerated Donald
Trump for extorting Zelensky, for withholding
lethal aid.
They withheld lethal aid until unless Zelensky
would release false smears against Joe Biden's
son.
And then he voted to exonerate President Trump
for this.
And so spare me the new solidarity with the
Ukrainians and with the free world because
this man's record is exactly the opposite.
Speaker 1: Who could say that a single word
of that is wrong?
And of course, Brian Schatz is right.
And you know, the stories, you know, the Ukraine
story, you know, the Josh Hawley insurrection
story.
So this is less about the facts that rant,
which is not.
I mean, listen, it's a soundbite, but it's
a two minute and 20 second sound bite.
It's a four hour modern expectations that
these things need to be 20 seconds long to
go viral.
It's two minutes and 20 seconds long.
And it's more substantive, and it's still
got over three million views.
It might even be up to four at this point.
So there is an appetite for this type of attitude
from the Democratic Party, and this is the
attitude that the Democratic Party needs to
take, hone the anger and keep calling out
the worst of the worst for their base individually.
Don't speak generally, speak individually.
Josh Hawley does a bad act, another humiliating
the word I'm not going to vote to approve
anybody confirm anybody to DOD until Trump's
secretary of defense resigns.
Biden, secretary of defense.
Give me a break.
That's absurd.
You're a senator.
You're one of 100.
You understand how government works, and it's
absurd that so many pretend that are supposed
concerns are genuine.
It's just nonsense.
Politically, it's political nonsense.
And so Democrats need to be making the statements,
and I'm going to use the term performing and
I don't use that pejoratively.
Democrats are often right on substance, but
they're not performing in the right way.
And it doesn't get any attention.
There is enough fodder from Republicans, from
what they are doing, from their hypocrisy
and double standards and absurdities for one
of these viral evisceration of a Republican,
basically every day.
Now you do it every day, it won't get as much
attention, but certainly every week.
And part of the issue is that Democrats don't
really have a media outlet that approaches
the power of Fox News.
I mean, you've got a 24-7 propaganda agenda
setting institution in Fox News.
And even if only a few million people watch
Fox News at any one point in time, their agenda
setting power is significant and then you
start seeing the same talking points everywhere
else.
This is sort of what Rush Limbaugh created,
where he it was the agenda setting power.
And so Democrats end up trying to catch up
and on defense.
And a lot of people I know are going to say,
But David, what about MSNBC?
MSNBC is a center left corporate media network,
and it is not the other side of the coin of
Fox News.
It's just not.
It's not even close.
It's not what it is, and it needs to be said
and repeated endlessly unless the left starts
doing more stuff like this.
And this is just one that you might say.
But David, this won't change anyone's vote.
This might change a few votes, but it's not
going to be enough to defeat Josh Hawley.
I don't even think he's up for election.
Maybe he is.
I don't know if he's up.
This time around, it doesn't matter.
But the point is, this is the attitude that
needs to be present everywhere as a minimum.
It won't even guarantee victory, but it's
got to change.
It's got to change because Democrats are just
not doing it in the right way